my picture of the week shows angela merkel
at the cdu party conference in essen
it is a demo cd he is shortly after
she almost begged her party
to support her in difficult times
as young european women the
current shift to the right in western
democracies scares me in the face of trump
the brh exit and nationalists the
lips and want that i am grateful for
a chancellor who at least defends
basic democratic values ​​and the
open society the
only question is how much longer she can do that i
don't know yet where i will put my cross in the
federal elections next year
maybe one of
the other candidates for chancellor will convince me in the end
[music]
actually, democracy lives on change
should angela merkel become chancellor again,
i wish that she would
continue
to fight for a policy of tolerance and
openness in an increasingly divided europe
[music]